[Music]
Julian podcast featuring armies and
onesies holiday brought to you by me and
easy as is this episode thanking me
Andes for sponsoring the Jillian podcast
guys you know that Mandy's also makes
the world's most comfortable lounge
pants auntie's and not to mention these
insanely cool onesies just so cool and
if you want to get lounge pants T's
undies onesies and everything Mandy's
for less than anyone else right now guys
you can join the membership and you get
special pricing okay get your 15% off of
your first pair of me at ease and free
shipping with a hundred percent
satisfaction guarantee by going to me
undies that's ME UND IES comm slash
Jenna Julianne those are our names
go to that website click the link below
and you'll get started also guys start
feeding your dogs the way they want to
be fed with the farmers dog farmers dog
is a service that sends you fresh
unprocessed food to feed your dog they
send you a box of it you freeze what
you're not going to feed them right away
and then you slowly put packages into
the fridge they make meal plans
specifically for your animal you fill
out a little questionnaire about your
pet how big they are what they like and
then farmers dog just takes care of
everything and your dog will be so happy
our dogs have loved the farmers dog they
look we call feeding time Benihana now
because they they love they love farmers
are so right now guys start feeding your
dog better get 50% off your first two
week trial of fresh healthy food at the
farmer's dog calm as th e FA RM ers do
g.com slash agenda Julianne check it out
you or your dog will not be disappointed
first of all I want to say I love this
onesie from Mandy's because it's like
one of the only ones that's made of a
thin fabric that I have so I would don't
get too hot wearing it love it amazing
ten out of ten and we call the dogs when
we feed them farmers dog we call it
going to Benihana because they you like
squeeze it out of the package
and it's like you know yeah actually
flat packages it's really convenient and
then on the especially marbles like you
have to like break it up for him or else
he won't eat it and he has to eat off
the floor or else he won't eat anything
he won't eat anything if it's on
anything or anywhere it needs to be flat
on the ground not even on a flat mat he
won't eat that yeah so we take two forks
and go you want to go to Benihana
he's the food out for for them and
Carmen teacher eating out of bowls like
dogs and motors on the ground and
Jillian takes two plastic forks so the
girls like Benihana it up yeah it's
really cheap yeah it's pretty cute yeah
they're in the show
but yeah these are well they feel like
the underwear it's like so soft oh yeah
are you ready ready for what this game
are you ready yeah well I suggested it
but like usually I'm the one that's like
making all the the games or stuff so
then we have Julian play but I was like
why don't you do one I want to play I do
something I want to play you play
someone you need sports trivia for me
okay
just because I'm better at celebrity
trivia I'm more entertaining to watch
doesn't make it make me not as good all
right so Jenna had this idea I usually
make games for you to play I want to
play a game Jenna had this idea it
sounded weird to me but I guess like it
makes sense you just play oh yeah what's
that sound
so I cook I compiled a whole list of
sounds and sound effects and Jenna's
gotta guess what they are
yeah you can you guys can play if you're
quick you know it's fun okay why you
doubt me sorry oh my god what nothing
don't yell me that it's fun oh okay all
right we're starting off with and what
are you wearing
all right what is that sound are you
guys ready to play what's that sounds
Benihana wake up it's the smell the
sounds with your ears
what's that sound
that's the podcast correct you got one
right wait did you miss the point of
this game I was thinking like animals
and like number two a moose or a dingo
incorrect on oh [ __ ] oh oh is it a boy
or a girl animal I don't know their
gender can you give me a hint because I
already get um oh okay it sounds like it
it should be some type of canine and/or
bear bear that's a good description of
how they look I mix between a canine and
a bear okay is that how you know yes
really that's a hot these are hyena
sounds but they're not that's not like
their pack sound that's not like their
no it's not like that yeah it's this is
just that they're like barking yeah it's
just like a normal operating sound by
the way by the way I was looking through
like I had to search I was just
searching something something sound
effect you know like I would just kind
of read something and then write sound
effect and I found this edit that's
someone made of the scene in spider-man
when Tobey Maguire was like feeling
himself and walking on the street but
there's no music and it's just like
normal audio and it's the funniest
napping and then you hear people's
reaction he's like this and they're like
oh it's so funny it's so funny okay
you're uh two for two sort of hyena okay
sound effect number whatever three
it sounds it sounded like someone
pouring a bowl of cereal but like more
specifically like it sounds a little
heavier than like rice puffs but likes
I'm feeling for a spot to run hear it
again
okay might might help to hear it again
listen for the weight in the texture my
guessing a specific no okay they sound
they're definitely heavier than cereal
so mmm it's an Epsom salt bath Epsom
salt is heavier than a grain of salt is
heavier than cereal okay think of it
okay
crystals what would you pour that's
heavier than cereal you wouldn't you in
poor rice but what what's somewhere in a
rice it sounds like race coffee beans oh
four three okay you you know what what I
do
it was just refilling coffee beans it
was a random one I threw a couple random
ones in here there's a couple of
nostalgic ones there's a couple derpy
ones and there's a couple really really
absolutely painfully boring ones so
buckle up okay
it sounds like somebody's sanding
something what that's I mean you're not
wrong this one's intense for what it is
it sounds like okay it's either somebody
using a pumice stone on the nasty-ass
foot like nasty dry ass [ __ ] heels or
someone using a very like low-grade
sandpaper to sand something with both
good guesses honestly I don't know how
this is not that scratching head you
gotta let me like give me some more
clues okay okay all right go get that
bread
it was definitely somebody scratching
something but that is to just soft
scratching into their their scalp with
their fingers think of their sharp nasty
fingers anyway next one but this is a
low-quality sound effect so disregard
like the part of it that's all think
about how it stops is it some type of
appliance yeah that's and that's
literally the length of how long it
would go a food processor no goodness
else good guess that's really a good yes
this is something very less pedestrian
that not the average person would have
in their home less pedestrian but if you
really loved to get that bread you might
have this bread maker No
oh it's a money counter
it's a breadmaker other kind of bread
I'm stupid nice okay good that's good
moving on peaches go away I love oh this
is such like an air you speed to play
this game at take your time on this one
that sounds like a moose or something
one sec wait wait what are you doing I
need to hear it okay you got I just had
to Google of moose and elk with the same
thing okay
Congrats you got that right this is an
elk sound yeah they wild they have never
never heard or even seen one of these
there hello have you ever seen them
fight with those [ __ ] horns No
well like reindeer I guess I'm out dude
these guys are gnarly I want to see I
want to see one of these guys go at it
be crazy like it's not like a ram like a
ram fight is like super intense but they
like they'll smack their ears but it's
not these guys are thick these these are
thick boys these are not like deer
they're like really yeah they're big
boys that's why they hide you know
they're hot yeah they're hot
what does that mean they're just hot
okay so angry why are all the dogs
trying to get on our laptop they don't
like that noise he's going away
literally go away hermit don't yell at
him he's got nothing to do with this
he's got a lot to do okay here we go
ooh okay this is first game just off the
top some type of mammal that sounds like
a mammal noise play it again actually
oh that's a good Oh cute oh oh that's a
kitten that's a kitten yeah yeah went
from kitten to like nasty cat these are
cat sounds which is a good transition to
what we're gonna do next which is just a
couple of animal sounds okay no like a
little section of animal sounds Oh like
it's a compilation okay no no I have a
list of them it's like a sound board and
I'm gonna click on random okay I'm good
at animal noises I'm starting please
I'll wait okay wait so that's all I get
that's all you get there quick there's
no quality because that sounds like
either it could be a shitty audio
recording of a dog painting or playing
it or like a bear scratching at a bear
safe no it's an ape not the best sound
yeah why I didn't record these okay I'm
sorry she's getting ready for quality
sound alright number two
okay that is a pack of race cars or play
it again
like sea lions or seals no vs. no it's
not it's a chorus of something not a
pack a race car okay a wasp it's not a
pack of race cards what is it not alpaca
race cards
it's an old packet oh wait these are
only two short yeah I know this is okay
yeah take it up with Google okay number
number number three
that's a bee or a while yellow just got
triggered by that yes I like bees though
how is this gonna be a sound I haven't
even tested this one yet
that's unfair i disqualified myself for
even she that was butterfly I was gonna
say that's someone drawing a very
elaborate picture in there butterflies
are dead silent that's someone
scribbling in their diary literally
butterflies don't make us sound that we
can hear it's just oh there's a
butterfly see the sound okay ready oh
that's kind of lit like that's kind of
got a beat okay go go that sounds like
the beginning of when in that vine the
guy puts the duck in there probably goes
yeah it's pretty simple is it a duck or
a goose or a bird it's avian lot of yeah
okay oh sorry I thought you were asking
me what it was okay next it's a cow good
let's see which other animal ones are
worth clicking on oh here we go
that's left
ledian okay I feel like that could be
like a frog or it could be a mammal okay
we've seen these person otter yeah Oh
cute good job it's definitely the sound
of like a mammal that likes to live in
the water or an amphibious animal that
makes animal noises fair enough all
right they have that like throaty yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay next one hold on
sorry okay that is like a lion Jaguar
tiger cheetah that's a wolf oh sorry let
me get there I'm sorry
though it's like a dog but in the wild
all right you know what okay I'm sorry I
actually I'm spaced I'm sorry for
spoiling that one here's another one
similar okay you should just play me
vine sounds and I'll tell you what they
are
okay that's the guy those interviewed on
the news when he's talking about what
yeah yeah dogs barking and his wife is
just like she's just standing there but
then somebody put his face and they're
like 21st Century Fox or whatever he's a
lion oh my god that's funny
good job good job thank you all right
next one we're moving away from animals
spongebob yes it's a spongebob certain
sound but you got it
it's what mood what mood is happening
when that sound we're hanging out in
bikini bottom
don't pander to me fake spongebob fan
yeah I don't know I don't really watch
oh god if you were to be watching the
show right and something happens and
then this sound plays
[Music]
that's what's happening what do you
think okay so just it's a disappointed
sound it's okay
can't win him on you got it you got it
you got okay ready
number number two total in the whole
game oh that's my foot
that's when you die in is it I don't
know some video again so you're Mario
you're on do it
nope Donkey Kong no sonic not Sonic give
me a hint
try played again just song not pong
[Music]
Goofy's matterhorn okay Python should
give you a hint sure your penis oh it's
the organ trail that's when you die in
organ trail yeah here lies your penalize
you penis we like when we started the
twitch stream years ago we played a game
orient Oregon Trail where we had one of
the characters named your penis
your penis died it said here lies your
penis I was like that was when we peaked
on twitch name is [ __ ] boring as hell
yeah yeah I was bad
okay ready mm-hmm I'm I just want to say
I'm really interested to see if you get
this one
I know is that it and one more cuz the
beginning sounds like when do did it
like it could be unsolved mysteries but
I know that it's not so is this from
like a TV show
is it from a videogame yes it's a video
yes
I'm not even sure if you played it it
definitely didn't well it's not a video
game
it's a video game system ooh
sega dreamcast is it is this what
happens when you press the power button
and it turns on it's the blue is the
boot sound and it's not sega dreamcast
no cuz i never had one of those is it a
switch or something new that I don't
have no it's very old very old um a
Super Nintendo never had one of those
it's um it's still around you know in
some version but this is the first it's
not a game boy that's not no no no it's
not yeah well you would know game boy I
think actually game boys in here
somewhere
yeah boys next is it a console Julius
sorry well since we're there is it
that's game or you know it is a console
yeah no I'm plenty oh I don't know why
I'd never played it
it's the PlayStation boot scream wake up
the first PlayStation
that's what happened when you turn on
the PlayStation which playstation ps1 I
believe there was also another screen
that I'm I haven't found yet that I'm
thinking of and I couldn't find it but
that's what that's like the main boot
sound for a Playstation ok you ready
mm-hmm
this one okay oh my god we'll play Wii
Sports
oh that's GameCube yeah that was I don't
know why you did that
I was playing one thing and then it's
heard playing another but yes that we
and then GameCube it's the main such a
good vine I love the Gamecube edit so
the Gamecube edits are pretty great all
right you might have already guessed
this one
[Music]
no idea you guessed it when I play the
ps1 sound is it like the switch is it a
Sega Dreamcast yeah Sega Dreamcast never
had one never played one but I know that
it existed I never played a Dreamcast
okay ready
yes oh that was tiny
so that's short and it's very similar to
the game Gameboy but it's not a gameboy
it's animal crossing it's uh this is
actually kind of a dumb one that I chose
but think of who makes game boy game boy
what company makes me okay what else do
they make hint the word Nintendo is in
the name you know it sounds like that
for sure but I don't know Super Nintendo
DSi Oh Super Nintendo yeah well speaking
of super here's the next one
wow what wow Julian why I can't have a
can of a transition to something oh the
Olympics just wait for it wait for it
wait
[Music]
yes it's the Olympics I just wanted you
to weigh it was and it still is yeah no
but I'm allowed to do it again because
it's a new podcast and we're it's
fitting into a new category oh okay yeah
hey you're a phenomenon we don't know
this for me thank you
[Music]
Julian's commercial is the goddamn
holiday mirror
I would be mad at you that kind of day
thank you for that transition that
wonderful commercial guys me undies man
what a great holiday gift if you don't
know what to get for your loved ones me
and these is a great option manatees is
so much softer than underwear that most
people have ever worn and its stylish
they have new designs all the time
wonderful onesie they have a bunch of
different colors of this you probably
don't even see the real color of this
right now because of the green screen
it's green and Jenna's is red but they
have all sorts of different designs of
the onesie they have lounge pants which
is the same exact material they have
t-shirts they have socks and most
importantly they have underwear
it's gonna be a hundred cent 100%
satisfaction guarantee if you don't like
it in any way shape form you will get
your money back but I am guaranteeing
you that you guys are gonna love it like
this their stuff is amazing okay and
they also have a membership system so if
you sign up to be a member you get all
the stuff I just listed but you get it
at their price because you're me andis
member you can also have subscription
plans where they send you stuff each
month or each week or whatever you want
to have delivered to your door you never
have to shop for underwear again I
haven't shopped for underwear in literal
years I used to hate that part of
shopping just going into the underwear
section and no me Andes takes the hassle
out of all that it's a no-brainer get
15% off of me undies calm / in and
Julian that's ME und IES comm /
annejulien check it out and you will not
be disappointed and your loved ones who
you buy the gift for will also not be
disappointed they will be happy also
guys the farmers dog is a solution to
the problem that you face when you want
to feed your dog some food that they
like but it's cost-effective for you and
easy and doesn't take a lot of time the
farmers dog cooks high quality real food
for your dog and it's for your dog
specifically you log on to the farmer's
dog comm / in Julian to get your nice
little 50% off of the first two weeks of
trial and you fill out a form about your
dog
the size their eating habits
what they like to eat when they eat how
often they everything about their food
in their diet and they will formulate a
plan of food and they'll send it to you
in a box and not every meal is the same
it has a bunch of different stuff that
they would like inside the food and I'm
telling you like we're on our second box
or a third box of me Andes which is like
our third second a third Montag sorry I
think Mandy's on the brain which means
we've been doing it for like almost
three months and the dogs have not even
close to gotten tired of it they love it
so much so check it out guys
us humans can't eat highly processed
food all the time so why should our dogs
eat the highly processed food check out
the farmer's dog calm / annejulien click
the link in the description you love
your dogs so give them the food that
they want and need they love to take
your dogs to Benihana dude all right
there we go
so moving on better ok I can't believe
you just played a commercial yes you can
that was someone using his stapler that
works at the DMV and now they're their
printer is out of paper that is not a
printer out of papers and when his
printer ever made that sound I don't
know what was the beginning of that the
beginning is a little drawn-out
it doesn't take this long that's not a
stapler hole puncher is this person in
an office no
is this an appliance yeah but it's out
in the world it's not in your house you
have to go buy a station to get this
train gas station but the fiddling
around with the gas pump at the
beginning was a little extra for me they
have the beeping in the back is kind of
a weird sound effect but it's okay you
didn't get that one next one
the micro
mr. Roger
and an air conditioner no but very close
and the microwave was also a good guess
but it's an air conditioner of sorts
conditions air in a certain way is it a
fan mm-hmm an air purifier no think more
simple a space heater yes
it's a furnace hell yes nice job so good
at guessing sound you're a beast next
one is a very good sound that we all
love to hear growing up
it's just like a lot of air okay ready
I'm gonna act it don't want I didn't act
this one out already okay good
Oh me and I'm tired and I want to relax
it's a static from a television did you
like my acting yeah that was really good
thanks baby you're so supportive okay
no idea
it's a little extra but it has something
to do with transportation like a bus
door open correct
you big beast yeah these are hard
they're not easy I know it's fun yeah
I'm trying to challenge you a little bit
here nice job sorry what was it it was
an astronaut
breathing Wow yeah I know I know that
sounds like someone steaming though I
know I was trying to make a whole
category here you'll see that's Darth
Vader
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's Kermit breathing it's kind of an
epic sound that's Kermit when he's
locked out of the bathroom we'll get
there
that's when you're programming a Casio
watch what if it goes anywhere a bomb a
stereotypical bomb in a movie all good
guesses it's so generic I thought I
would kind of oh it's like a heart
monitor in a hospital life support
I have no excuse number two
a coffee maker yeah [ __ ] this is like a
two minute recording and a whole
sequence yeah it's a coffee machine
brewing sighs that sounds good
I like that phone that doesn't good that
makes me feel like it's morning I know
on a cold winter day you got a nice
fresh day ahead of you oh just don't
trip out the front door oh this one's a
terrible one skipping it and it's all
right okay
here we go
that someone using like a table saw no
it does sound a lot like that though
[Music]
is that like a pressure washer nice job
nailed it
thank you you're a beast all right
this is just a generic sound this could
be on a lot of different things or items
but it is one specific component to
those things
like Oh a forklift hydraulic lifts so
yeah that's the hydraulics yeah nice
okay that's the lion in the movie which
one two different movie studios that
you're doing century 21st century no
bugs no yeah no that's not 21st Century
Fox what's it called
you know I know what are you it's the
circle isn't a circle a circle there's
gold
yeah AMC stop it there's a the UFC hold
a lot of fights in an arena named after
this place MGM yes see all you need to
do is apply yourself when it comes to
UFC and violence and you understood okay
next one I hope you can tell the theme
we're going with no oh [ __ ] what is that
oh [ __ ] look is that movie studio it's
not DreamWorks mmm-hmm it's a longer
version of it yeah what do ya I like I
don't know the names of all these things
that Kurtz and we're just being alive
[Music]
[Music]
would it help if I described it'll look
like and then he gets the name of it
because it doesn't have the name sure
it's a lighthouse yeah I don't know the
names of all yeah this one's kind of
tough castle rock castle right yeah but
you knew it was hard to remove yeah okay
that was difficult
[Music]
I feel like I'm about to watch a movie
right now I love this feeling is that
Disney no you do
it's a woman holding it it's a statue of
a woman holding up yeah I know but I
don't know the name what that is think
about the words behind her just picture
the words behind her paramount clothes I
don't know hmm
where's your brother you go to school
Cornell damn it I thought I was the
other one it sucks I see it's a very
good school Columbia
yeah sorry I [ __ ] that up I thought
was quite actually okay it just says go
ahead in red
big red this one DreamWorks describe the
scene though it's like a person they
cast a fishing line into a pool of water
and the bobber Bob's up and down and
then they zoom out and it's thrown
across some of this [ __ ] nice good
you're a beast I got next one
these aren't sounds you know what I'm
doing a whole eclectic mix of audio and
you need to just play along
I'm sorry being played oh they already
passed
is that the one that plays before like
Marvel or DC movies or whatever and it's
just like shuffling through that it's
it's marvel yes it's the shuffling yeah
that's pretty stupid thanks babe
no not you stupid that sounded stupid
pics are sweet they're easier to get in
context of like movie opens different
theme okay a fart machine this is fart
sounds farts on there's a poop so you
want to keep going we got like 15 more
seconds there you go - how's your day
been what do you have planned for later
I got two alright just the thing very
basic here
[Laughter]
what did you just hear what was a man
yelling yes correct
you nailed it you're so good at this
camp next one more specific a man
yelling there's a name for that one
they stubbed their toe no really bad no
I don't know see do you nothing special
pops up in your head about that one no
okay that one's called the Wilhelm
scream it's like a very famous scream
sound effect that's been in a million
movies it's like one single I don't know
it's just a it's a weird what was that
no it's the flight attendant sound it's
yeah it's the seatbelt sound yeah
seatbelt sign yeah the flight attendant
sound they just walk up to your seat and
they go when you push the call button
yeah it's this it's the I just heard
that noxious so I knew that was a plane
sound okay um wondering if I should even
play this one this one's pretty hard but
you might get it it's something
[Music]
step ahead
[Music]
yeah this is impression to pick this one
that sounds like someone playing rock
band it was the original old old intro
for Ultimate Fighter or the UFC rather
sorry these are songs yeah they're
sounds all right the next one is just a
sound I promise that promise is not a
song what is the puppy doing hungry
what's he doing he's locked in a crate
what do you think yeah it's the action
yes
[Music]
a bear yes really there it is a bear
effect bear sound effect growling but
like you can hear it when it comes in
there no you haven't but I can tell oh
my god I used to have a toy that made
that noise it's like it's the one that I
was like a stick and you like flip it
over similar yeah but do you also know
what this is what is it
it can walk you put it at the top of the
stairs it slinky yes nice good job I
think this one's really unfair but
you're kind of a beast so I'm gonna see
if you can get it actually no that's
family feud what's how the [ __ ] that was
literally just a plain buzzer how did
you get that cuz that's family feud I I
was gonna like Nix it cuz it's so unfair
but you guess you could guess that
that's family feud yeah but she sounds
like a buzzer yeah but I don't know okay
so I decided to take a crazy step
outside the box for the last one and
play songs no this is a really wild one
and I want to play for you see if you
get the beginning of a porno what was
that
just someone walking in heels footsteps
sound effect
I wanted to get a little crazy for the
last one sound effect footsteps woman
walking slowly HD HQ sound effect
playlist here so I thought I would just
end it with the bang there what I wanted
to pick an exciting one to end on keV
late again tell me this is not exciting
thank you
what you can't say I didn't pick good
sounds these are a good mix of sounds
that was a fun game I like that game I
like the animal sounds the most though
you like the animal song yeah okay let's
go back to that no not that sound boards
are hard I can see well there you go
that was guest that sound she's been
waiting this whole time to get a hug
those are that sound and you guessed it
that was fun what sometimes I'll do some
for you I think I think that would be
fun I would probably Nate nail all of
them all of them yeah I wouldn't mmm
just like why was Sweet Caroline in
there I don't know the sound Oh a song
is a sound I had to mix it up you know
I'll let you get why was the Olympics
thing if I let you get too comfortable
right just put a bunch of spongebob
sounds in there you're having a good
time I got yeah
I had to mix it up okay if you look back
at the ride we just took we went through
childhood nostalgic sounds movie sounds
yeah Boston sounds animal sounds yeah
all right well it's a good game I like
what's that song hey listen if you
didn't like all the sounds I picked
that's what the dislike button is for
feel free jump away what what I'm trying
to just give them a choice well I don't
know I initially I was like this is a
weird sounding game unattended but then
I then I thought this was cool because I
I think going through the sounds I'm
like actually because I would search for
one then you find more I find when I was
like making mini categories like the
astronaut Darth Vader and then the dog
barking and then the guy being the dog
barking you played along hopefully you
did good it makes me want to play a game
called finish that vine where you play
the beginning of a vine for me and I
finish it should play that why cut can
we restart let's do that next week
finish that vine but we show these to
Roy and alright I'm gonna put your
little vine crown to the test
Roy dang okay let's how about this we do
it so you you have like 30 vines and I
have 30 vines and they cannot be they're
gonna be the same no no no no the same
we're both disqualified of them the
podcast ends we're gonna have some that
are the same okay
well we'll try our best to get 30
separate lines we can try oh my gosh
so one of us just picks all the vines
the other has to finish all of them I'm
gonna finish every single vine or we
could just play a vine compilation' and
just positive halfway through and then
the yeah that's bad that's Aries um
alright so wait so I'm compiling the
vine you have to finish them I'll do
that I'll do that I'm gonna stump you no
I'm gonna stomp you nice Ron oh just
give me some just fire away
Adam wait that's the end no that
happened before he says I'm doing the
first part now oh good
Richard that's oh come on keep going
welcome its first of all it's hi welcome
know did you know
welcome to know already welcome to Bible
studies yeah I threw you off you're
waiting for the Chili's line I got you
because it is Bible School welcome to
Bible study yeah I forget what she says
I think it's welcome to Bible study
we're all children of God okay hi
welcome to Chili's oh my god I threw you
off again hi are you Javier okay I still
got it oh good good um kind of think you
have a good one [ __ ] plus he doesn't say
hi he just says are you Javier uh I
think he says hi look it up go ahead
play it I'm finding it I got how do I
put sound on for these oh wait how do I
just be on YouTube knows what are you
doing I'm trying to it's on vine but you
can read his lips he says hi okay sir
I'm finding it I'm finding I'm finding
it it's just Chris mobile your vine
compilation'
hi are you Javier it has to be here all
it is compilation' I'm fine I am looking
through well have to just listen to
Chris mother divine hi are you Javier
was one of the more newer ones I think
[Music]
I'm gonna find out
hi are you Javier dammit [ __ ] hmm well I
personally think it I guess I'll have to
leave it up to mystery I think he said
hi are you happier you can't find it
anywhere just by yourself ready road
work its first of all it's road work
ahead I'm doing yeah I hope it does I'm
doing yeah ok I'm just doing little bits
to not give it away
drew gooden good good good good good kid
here oh hi I didn't see you there I was
just mmm blocking out the haters brandon
bowen really mom I'm gonna say the
artist as well
welcome to Radio Shack AK but it's so
funny because I feel like the vines that
we're gonna choose are gonna be so like
I don't know not every vine compilation'
you watch cuz we liked I mean you liked
a lot of different wines got popular in
compilations that weren't really that
popular on vine like Drew Gooden is like
road work ahead was not one of his more
popular vines on vine it only became
popular on YouTube yeah and in their
compilation yeah it's like a weird
you're totally right that different
things popularized differently after
vine was dead yeah on YouTube it's weird
yeah keep going I love this game I can
play it all day I know you do this can
go um hi my name is
tray I got basketball game ma play point
cargo shoe game I love them vines this
went on and then cut off and then that
was it
oh man mmm I'm trying to think every
person that gotta do watch today yeah
you're actually like if there was an
ability to major in line history and
content you would be a major I'm up
there you would have that degree you
would be teaching that degree I can do
it you be a professor of Vine University
going why don't you just type in vine
and just you can see what pops up but to
inspire you because I'm ready to play
all right I'm just gonna put on silent
what is this podcast anymore I love it
del Taco we got this new thing called
free - free Shabbat canoe
BAM nice I don't know her name I thought
I don't know her name she wasn't really
a whiner though she was just delightful
two shots of vodka that's a clip from
like a TV show hey all right
you know what this would be better
suited if I had time to curate a couple
one mmm stumpy you can do it can't stump
you on the spot I'm like struggling to
even like come up with random ones vines
that I think about every day
Oh Oh
countries that ask me no asking what
kind of trees uh it's a Chris Pine well
done I think I think we should do this
next week I personally think we should
do
vine taking you to vine school taking
you to vine University vine college vine
trivia something like that
why isn't there like trivia nights at
bars with vine that would be good
we should know we should start that we
should make a bar just so there could be
like vine trivia we should make a bar
just yeah it's a simple way to do it
instead of suggesting doing my job yet
oh yeah trying to obtain a liquor
license I'm just trying to have vine
trivia drunk I asked for liquor license
I watch laws I have a license we love
you
whenever you're ready anyway I hope you
guys enjoyed listening and maybe playing
along - what's that sound
hopefully I didn't do such a trash job
but you'll never listen to this podcast
again but if you did thank you for
hanging out good for me that's my
opinion
the blinking is like a whole second half
though can you imagine being someone
that never watched wine and like never
got into any of that listening to a
podcast of people just finishing each
other if you're it would be like
infuriating for one but also just like
straight up gibberish doesn't even sound
like English yes but that's how we like
it
that's honestly if people can watch our
podcast and leave with something in
their head saying I have no idea what I
just did for the last two hours I'm
happy I think we did our job well we'll
see you guys next Monday
for some vine sweet spicy mimin maybe
and hopefully hopefully we can get that
if we don't we'll get something
completely different done and it won't
have anything to do with overtime
because there's no rules
have a good week and we'll see ya on the
next one
[Music]